chair we're now live on youtube so the
meeting can start
thank you very much indeed chris um
good good morning and welcome to the
nice uh
the um the licensing committee
um it is a sad week because of the
uh passing of his royal highness the
duke of edinburgh
i believe the full council will be
holding a
silence and it will give the opportunity
of all councillors to give
their uh their condolences to her
majesty the
queen um so i'll first of all on the
first
item on the agenda's apologies beth can
you tell me if there are any apologies
other than
counsellor i believe russell had said
she was not available
yes chair cancer russell and councillor
hayes both given apologies today
thank you very much indeed uh neither
apologies um can i ask councils are
there any declarations of interest
nope i think we can
safely go on to that um could i
therefore have your approval to
sign the minutes of the meeting held on
the 14th of october
29th of october and 26th of october
where
uh and prove that they are a correct
record uh for me to sign up her later
date
proposed by councillor nutley second i
think councillor hawking just beat you
to it
thank you very much indeed um
sorry um sorry to interrupt uh the
minutes of the meeting's held on the 6th
of january and 11th of march
oh i got the wrong ones sorry oh yes i
have sorry
yep sorry the dates could i
amend those dates sorry
i haven't sorry i've got the wrong
you've got me wrong dates are that down
is everybody happy with those dates for
the minutes yeah
yeah that's great thank you very much
indeed that's sorry chairman
uh seconded by councillor hawking and i
think approved unanimously
lovely thank you chair
uh uh
in attendance today obviously the
committee uh is the are the members of
the committee also um
beth from democratic services and andrea
who's the licensing manager who will be
in a minute be taking us through um
a new new policy i think looks like
um andrew's disappeared on the screen
there
we open us back again
so um could i hand over to you uh
andrea as licensing manager to present
this next item
yes fine thank you very much um good
morning
we're here this morning to seek approval
to temporarily
excuse me i can't say the word deviate
from the hackney carriage and private
hire policy
that currently requires a driver's
assessment certificate
prior to the issue of a driver's license
due to the pandemic the driver and
vehicle standards agency
following government guidance have
suspended
driving lessons or driving tests
and our driving assessments fall within
this criteria
therefore we've been unable to process
any new drivers
as they've been unable to attend the
driver's assessment
and therefore unable to meet the policy
requirement we were under
we were understood that the current
suspension was due to be lifted
on the 22nd of april but i've
subsequently received an email this week
to say that our driving assessment
provider
um we'll be resuming their driving
assessments
from the 12th of april which was monday
just gone
however there still is like perhaps
12-month
bags backloggers drivers wanting
to do this carry out the assessment
so therefore until such time as the
covid restrictions are permanently
lifted
and everything is as back to normal as
can be
that new drivers be able to provide a
copy of their driving assessment
certificate
within four months of their licence
being issued
if the assessment is not completed
within this time scale
without a reasonable explanation for
example
the driving assessments are suspended
again or the driver
fails the assessment the license will be
suspended until such
time as the assessment has been
completed and a copy of the certificate
is sent to licensing chair committee are
asked to
approve this temporary request
thank you colleagues have you all read
the uh report
and are there any questions for andrea
about the report i think it's a pretty
uh straightforward um
and sensible policy but um if there are
any questions
counselor hawking yeah
no objection to to the request i'm just
wondering if um
andrew could actually just take us
through how we
as a council make sure that um these
people do stick
to the fact that we're really releasing
this a bit
um because obviously there's got to be
checks
uh and we're obviously responsible um i
just want to know
that these checks will be done and how
do we make sure
or keep an eye on the fact that we are
releasing it we we have a
a spreadsheet that we have been keeping
since the pandemic because it's an
electronic way of
test checking that every documentation
is received prior to the issue of a
license
and these drivers will be marked as
not attaining the assessment with the
deadline date put in there of when
that's required
so we can keep an eye on that so that
spreadsheet is constantly being updated
thank you council rollington thank you
chair
um i do have a problem
in the parrot it says in the risk
assessment on the report
the paramount objective is to ensure
public safety
and we need to see that people are fit
and proper to hold
the license i'm if it's paramount
and we've been doing this task and we
intend to
see that it's done in the future i i i
would think that
we our duty to safeguard the public
should be upheld and i would think that
would incorporate
our um safeguarding policy because there
may be vulnerable
people or even children that
are included in the general public that
may be at risk here so
i'm not sure that for another four
months
uh or however long it takes to uh clear
the backlog
is a reason enough to accept this risk
into in terms of our duty of care to the
public
i don't know how i could defend that if
god forbid something did go wrong or
whatever it may not
but you you that that's our job isn't it
and i think
kovit has produced some real hardships
and difficulties but
i think people obtaining their license
is and the difficulties that presents
them
is not a bigger risk as having people
there that we can't be sure of it and
proper
chair i i would actually propose that um
we we keep the status quo until the
backlog's cleared
you know right um i'm just going to ask
andrew do you want to come back
back and then i'm going to have a say on
that one yeah
um no it is he's perfectly right we've
brought this in for a reason for
a purpose but unfortunately due to the
pandemic we've had
quite a few drivers that have decided to
retire earlier than planned
so we've also we're also being mindful
of those companies that are finding
difficulty
in being able to get drivers
back working so we're also trying to
think about the
the businesses and the people that are
trying to get employed within this
circumstance type times of year where
they
they can't work or have not have lost
jobs through
other reasons throughout the pandemic so
i can perfectly understand
mr rollerson's um
and what's been put into the into the
report
i think we've got to balance carefully
and i would fall down on the side of
helping people get jobs
um after um uh
covid and uh we have people that there
are jobs for people there are people who
want to be employed
people want to employ them there are
people who want to use them people uh
need some people rely on taxis for
transport
um so yes i agree that it is balancing a
risk but i think it's
it's a short-term risk to deal with an
exceptional
uh circumstance with a pandemic um so i
i my personal view is we should go ahead
with them
adopt the report um but although any
other comments from any other
councillors
chair i just want to emphasize that a
lot of sympathy with the jobs obviously
and a lot of cases where we could
prioritize
uh getting jobs i don't think in this
case
jobs are our paramount objective
um and there's a particular reason why
people need to be seen to be fit and
proper i guess if
their passengers and public are getting
into their taxes
i just don't think the the case is made
on this particular occasion about the
jobs and i
would put a proposal that if anyone want
to second it that
we just maintain the status quo and work
through it
thank you chair thank you thank you
council
um are there any other comments from
councillors
gaza hawking yeah thank you chair
um what what have we done over the last
12 months
um surely we've had um drivers in that
that
other their licenses run out and that
need to be renewed
and whatever you what so what have we
done over the last 12 months
while the dvla have not been able to do
do the testing that is required for them
to do
um if we've if we've not done anything
apart from just
log the fact that the license has run
out because
they clearly can't get a retest or
get a test then i i can't see
what the problem is um i do understand
what kinds of ronin has said
but i think i i tend to agree with you
that we need to um you know need to be a
little bit sensible about this at the
moment
thank you thank you councillor is there
any seconder for councillor ronson's
proposal or status quo
um i'm not seeing anybody seconding uh
your motion
council runs and so i think that means
it will fall
and i'm going to propose from the chair
that we adopt the
the report as set out i don't disagree
with council rollins and i'm sure
uh the licensing manager is is very is
very
um aware of the of the of the situation
but i think on the on the pro
on balance and the need to get society
working again and get people
into jobs and get and get things moving
again after the pandemic i think
i think i would think i would come down
on supporting the report so i'm going to
propose from the chair
that we adopt the report as set out can
i have a second
please counselor nutley seconded
could ask for all those in favor
that's by a majority uh and obviously
council roninson
obviously uh you're oh i'm sorry all the
posing sorry
thank you very much would you like your
vote recorded council robinson
yes thank you for the offer thank you
yeah
thank you much could that be recorded um
thank you chair yes that's passed
is that passed okay um move on to item
five request for a hackney carriage
vehicle extension for
uh romeo oscar 10 victor victor papa
um licensing manager have you anything
to add to your report
yes um the vehicle is obviously now 10
years and 9 months old which is outside
of our 10-year policy
yeah the vehicle the vehicle passes
expecting it's his
rear the vehicle passes expect
inspection on the 7th of april
and have no advisories the mot expires
on the 31st of august
and the vehicle was checked by a
licensed officer on the 17th of march
and the photos are attached in
appendix c of the report the
applicant or the driver isn't in
attendance but he has sent through
um a letter if you're happy for me to
read that from him
certainly yep he says dear chair and
counsellors
apologies for not being able to present
at the hearing
but i am employed in a different role
work role during the week
i would like to appeal for an extension
to my vehicle
romeo i don't know the outfit i'm sorry
r010 vvp
a white vauxhall insignia the license is
due to expire on the 22nd of april
2021 the vehicle was in excellent
mechanical and physical condition
inside and out due to the current
climate and the high cost of replacing
this vehicle with one that is under five
years old
i hope that the committee will look
favorably upon my request
i have presented my vehicle to the
licensing officer
who confirmed that it was in good
physical condition
the vehicle has passed the taxi test and
had no advisories
you're safely mohammad hussein
would you thank him for writing in i
think that's very helpful to us um
i think any questions in the public
public domain for licensing officer
bunny of the councillors
i think the report's pretty uh
is is pretty good um beth can we go in
did are people happy to go to private
session for determining this
yep beth could we go into private
session so
uh we would stop uh live streaming so
that we can decide
on this application yes thank you chair
uh just for any members of the public
that are watching on youtube just to
confirm that
uh we will stop live streaming so that
committee can go into private session
to um decide the the um application
um we won't be coming back to live
streaming but the applicant will be
informed later today of the committee's
decision and then
a full written decision notice will be
given within five working days
and